la séance a commencé par une
intervention plutôt ferme de belfort
birota le président du service
départemental de secours et d'incendié
membres de la majorité
tenet a dénoncé les propos du président
du conseil exécutif alfred marie-jeanne
sur une radio de rivière pilote
le mois dernier des propos qu'il
qualifie d' assassin y nation un pack
hot que son positionnement politiciens
de créer un trouble considérable aux
10es fait que je suis fragilisé dans ma
gestion de mon autorité
ajoutez à cela le manque d'argent
c'est à dire que la contribution de la
collectivité rurale de la martinique qui
devait être versée dans son intégralité
aux 10 n'a pas été fait le 10 seraient
en attente de 4 millions d'euros de la
ctn pour belfort birota ce serait même
la cause de la récente grève des
pompiers
autre temps fort de cette plénière la
question de l'acquisition par la ctm de
photos prises par un professionnel d'une
réunion du parti pays à de jean-philippe
ni l'or
or dans sa progression
le deuil du stade ni n'ai jamais dit le
responsable tchétchène alex idée de nous
ce monde en question et des suivantes
que ce soir dit ici c'est officiellement
que c'était une tactique c'était de
nadine pâte a lieu je tiens à dire qu'on
appelle une pratique de mai à l'ordre du
jour de la plénière il y avait surtout
l'examen du compte administratif 2010 8
les finances de la ctm se porterait
mieux en terme de chiffres il y en a un
qui est très important c'est
effectivement le résultat est bien
l'année dernière en détail sur un
déficit de 1 million et demi à peu près
cette année on est sur un montant de
cinq cent mille euros
nous sortons d'une situation d' alerte
absolue qui était celle que nous avons
trouvé avec le compte administratif 2015
pour arriver dans je dirais des
pratiques qui soir plus satisfaisante en
tout cas plus rassurante
le budget 2010 9 de la ctm se monte à ce
jour à 1 milliard 200 millions d'euros